welcome back we got some breaking news
to bring you now and this is quite a
significant story the high court has
been ruling on whether or overturned a
decision or not to extradite julian
assange to the united states where he is
accused of publishing classified
military documents well i can tell you
the us government has won its appeal
that is at the court of appeal uh
obviously you'll recall that uh
initially julian assange courts ruled
that he should not be extradited to the
united states where he is of course
wanted for publishing classified
documents the u.s government appealed
that decision in the court of appeal and
it has won that appeal julian assange of
course currently being held on remand at
belmarsh prison in south east london a
very big dramatic ruling there you can
see these are live pictures right now
outside the court of appeal where julian
assange's supporters have been gathering
he has of course had some very high
profile supporters on his recent course
appearances including the former leader
of the opposition the lead former leader
of the labour party jeremy corbyn he has
been among those who have gathered
outside the courts in the past where
julian assange has uh has had his
court's uh cases heard so just to
reiterate that uh breaking news that we
have just received
the u.s government has won in the court
of appeal
on its uh the original high court
decision not to extradite julian assange
to the united states where he is accused
of publishing classified
military documents as i say the court
ruled earlier this year that he should
not be extradited the u.s government has
won its appeal in the court of appeal as
i said these are live scenes
there is julian assange
says i'm not sure whether he was
actually in court today he has been on
remand in belmarsh prison the former
wikileaks founder and whistleblower the
united states obviously has been
fighting for many years to extradite him
to the u.s you will of course recall
that uh initially he was holed up in the
ecuadorian embassy here in london for a
number of years that was while
an earlier extradition request from the
swedish government was going through the
courts uh the swedish government wanted
to extradite mr assange on uh
allegations of uh sexual uh misconduct
in uh sweden uh those uh court that
caught that case was eventually of
course uh time barred by uh by the
lapsing of time so the swedish
government dropped their attempts to
extradite julian assange in the meantime
of course uh the us went ahead with
their calls to extradite julian assange
we will have more on that as we get it